mais madame pour l'instant personne ne
dit que c'est du racisme pour le moment
tu as raison et si le comité dit
l'inverse ce n'est donc pas de Normandie
j'entends qu'il retourne en Afrique les
migrants et tant qu'on est pas sûr que
et ça s'adressait à Monsieur je trouve
que là il y a une petite récupération
politique quelque chose
un petit peu est très mauvaise il vaut
mieux qu'il retourne en Afrique
si personne n'est d'accord ici c'est
pour l'instant ouais je suis très gêné
parce qu'en fait je je comprends qu'il y
a une sorte de cohésion et de solidarité
au niveau de l'Assemblée nationale où
tout le monde a entendu ça mais malgré
tout moi je n'entends pas ça donc je je
suis très genre alors pluriel
alors tiens merci alors un autre ami
Adama Traoré tu es plus blessé mon
frérot je suis content déjà
c'est bien si tu veux je peux te Daniel
et moi faisons des massages à 80 si tu
as besoin voilà n'hésite pas ça mon
frérot tu es enfant un peu comme
d'habitude quand je vais essayer je suis
toujours triste pourquoi quand j'entends
les propos que la personne à ma droite a
pu proférer hier et les propos de madame
je me pose vraiment des questions sur le
devenir de notre beau pique qui
s'appelle la France mais je pense qu'il
était plus en profondeur et ben on
discute ensemble
alors c'est vrai qu'on a eu hier on va
revoir la scène à l'Assemblée nationale
hier là qui a fait énormément parler ça
a été d'ailleurs des battu aujourd'hui
regardez
vous vous saisir de la question de la
répartition des migrants avec et
d'autres pays européens comme Malte qui
ne répond plus aux demandes de cotation
de sauvetage les personnes secourues se
trouvent dans une situation d'urgence
absolue des prévisions météo indiquent
une détonation significative du climat
pas du tout
voilà ce que je disais aussi hier à ce
que je ne sais pas parler avec Carlos
hier
s'il vous plaît j'ai parlé avec lui et
je lui disais sois fier de ce que tu es
soit fier de ce que tu es devenu on a
parlé ensemble après il a compris ce que
je lui dis et je disais voilà que tu
ailles toutes les semaines au contraire
porter ta voix et aller
et si tu viendras ici aussi porter ta
voix pour autre chose et c'est le plus
important il a 31 ans je suis hier c'est
vrai que c'est une réussite incroyable
il a été élu et c'est vrai qu'il a dit
un truc seul truc est vraiment mon art
parler après il a dit un truc ça c'est
vrai il a dit c'est vrai que si ça avait
été un autre député plus connu ou plus
égérie jamais il aurait été coupé comme
ça c'est vrai que ça je suis assez
d'accord avec lui là dessus ça c'est sûr
Adama qu'est-ce qui t'a choqué dans les
dans ce qui s'est dit ce que moi choqué
par rapport à ce qu'elle a pu dire
Mathieu hier sur le sens qu'il paquet ou
qui parle d'un bateau qui parle d'êtres
humains avoir un élu de la République
française au sein de l'hémicycle avoir
des discours ou des sémantique Jean de
de
discours dans un café du coin moi je
trouve ça juste intolérable regarde
ce qu'il a dit hier c'est que déjà il
commence à remettre en question ou en
doute les dire de députés presque à
Monsieur comme il va y avoir un comité
donc pour l'instant
hormis le comité il y a une éthique
l'éthique qui est porté par des élus de
la République et un milieu de la
République française monsieur qui va
dans l'hémicycle qui a ce genre de
propos retourner en Afrique moi tu es le
personnel qui qui subit ce genre de
propos à longueur de journée moi ça me
choque monsieur aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont entendu
pardon comme Géraldine on entend qu'il
retourne en Afrique en parlant c'est pas
la même chose mais c'est pas la même
chose
mais c'est pas retourne en Afrique
c'est pas le même sujet
parce que peut-être malheureusement par
rapport à nos différences de
pigmentation de peau vous et moi
peut-être on vit pas les mêmes choses on
entend pas les choses dans la même
manière maintenant je parle d'un
véhicule que j'ai vu au quotidien avoir
un milieu de la République qui doit
représenter l'ensemble des Français qui
connaît dans mon histoire de son pays
exemple l'article 1 du préambule de 46
qui lutte contre tout ce genre de propos
normalement une personne qui connaît un
minimum son histoire ne peut pas obtenir
ce genre de propos notamment un élu de
la République rassemblement national LFI
ça on n'est pas là c'est pas le sujet en
fait le sujet c'est comment aujourd'hui
nous français on peut soit tolérer au
pas tolérer qu'un élu de la République
peut tenir ses propos et on peut retenir
ses propos ou accepter ses propos ou les
tolérer ses propos pour une chose si on
est si on est xénophobe car au final il
s'adressait pas au début
vous prenez vous tirez de l'aile
monsieur
porté par l’élite de la République vous
tournez pas de son groupe politique qui
sera à ce moment national qui soit
éléphant le Premier ministre que vous
êtes en train de dire Adama Adama Adam
Adama Adama est-ce que tu es en train de
dire
Adama
raciste
voiture
qui a été effectivement maladroitement
le sujet c'était de parler de
l'Immigration et de l'immigration
illégale c'était ça le sujet et ce qui
m'ennuie moi c'est que pour le moment
chacun a entendu ce qui devait entendre
et au monsieur attends si et
heureusement et qui fait de la
récupération politique
pour l'instant nous ce qu'on vient de
faire de la récupération donc ça n'a pas
été prouvé il y a pas raciste
évidemment
que si c'est pour le condamnation
jusque en train de dire Adama Adama il
dit que
soit la version kill qui est le pluriel
c'est quoi qu'il arrive après après
juste hier et je me fais voilà je me
fais voilà je fais l'avocat de de déjà
dîner et de Mathieu moi je comprends
tout à fait ce que tu dis à la masse son
quoi qu'il arrive les propos ils sont
inadmissibles
singulier au kilo pluriel c'est une
amitié
Géraldine ils étaient sur le fait que
comme le monsieur était là le député ils
étaient juste en train de dire quoi avec
son quoi qu'il arrive eux je te le dis
Matthieu et géralique soit Matthieu
Géraldine il trouve une admissible que
ce soit qui au pluriel ou kilo singulier
juste là il disait au député hier est-ce
que c'est bien contre vous ou pas contre
là c'est ça en fait c'est c'est
quoi qu'il arrive d'accord avec toi à
cause des conditions climatiques et je
rappelle que ça aurait été des Italiens
qui veulent venir on aurait dit que les
Italiens retournent en Italie ça
n'aurait pas fait cette polémique
par rapport au fait que certaines
personnes par rapport à un discours
ambiance à certains à travers certains
canaux médiatique que retourne en
Afrique c'est devenu juste normal c'est
pas normal
alors que moi alors que moi quand je
vois l'émission de JR désolé mais on
voit des des des personnes de TPMP
prendre la défense d'un député en
activité quand tu as une des propos
xenovo
de couleur forcément il a raison mais
c'est ce que tu es en train de me dire
aucun moment je vous ai parlé du
débutant en question qui signifie
je te le dis je pense que
j'aurais dit Mathieu peuvent venir
il cautionne pas du tout ce qui a été
dit s'il vous plaît
hier on découvre la séquence peut-être
ça s'était passé une heure avant
l'émission donc on découvre cette sorte
de petit extrait voilà et moi
effectivement quand Siri ne me demande
ce que j'en ai pensé j'entends qu'il
retourne en Afrique et donc je dis que
c'est pas pour moi une accusation et une
injure
contre le monsieur
et je dis d'ailleurs au préalable que 6
il dit retourne en Afrique à ce monsieur
c'est très grave et d'ailleurs madame
panaud a dit que il risquait finalement
pas grand chose parce que là c'est un
délit c'est pas une opinion du racine
c'est un délit il doit être chimique
très sévèrement voilà après entre temps
je travaille
je découvre un peu qui est le député qui
a profé
ses insultes et effectivement on exume
des truites immondes
d'animal Sophie Leclerc
donc effectivement là je me dis bon ok
si c'est pas une attaque adnienne contre
ce monsieur malgré tout il y a une sorte
de de terreau chez cette personne qui me
semble assez nauséabonde et dégueulasse
oui mais encore une fois Monsieur le
groupe politique il existe il y a des
millions de gens qui votent pour pour
eux et ces millions de gens ne sont pas
forcément
diabolise mais il y a tellement de gens
qui votent pour eux qu'il faut se poser
aussi des bonnes questions
au gouvernement de pro Macron de
processeuse donc je suis ni extrême
droite ni extrême gauche mais malgré
tout attention aussi à une récupération
qui va normalement faire du mal faire du
mal à à la cause au racisme qui est
juste une gangrène voilà
penser pour moi les propos qu'il a pu
tenir il a pu tenir par rapport au
bateau certes vous savez madame il fut
un temps en France c'est un truc
s'appelle le Code noir ou on assimilé
des êtres humains à des biens meubles
mais moi je la poste quand j'entends les
excuses qui sont donnés par rapport au
propos qu'il a pu tenir cette élu du
rassemblement national c'est comme son
nom elle parle pas des étriers par le
bateau il parle du bateau mais dans le
bateau il y a des êtres humains
aujourd'hui
dans les rapports
par rapport à ce que vous dites vous
savez ce qui a choqué vraiment l'opinion
publique madame c'est le fait qu'un
milieu de la République au sein de
l'hémicycle il a pu tiré des propos
qu'on attend normalement on part du coin
au restaurant du coin mais vous devez
aujourd'hui
madame les les personnes qui ont voté
pour cette élu que vous dites c'est bien
soit disant ils sont des millions
exactement le contraire toutes les
personnes qui vous dites si bien qu'ils
ont voté pour le rassemblement national
qui sont
si aujourd'hui eux ils peuvent tolérer
des propos xénophobes tenus par leur élu
au sein de 2006 qui donne une mauvaise
image de la fonction de l'homme
politique en France madame c'est vous et
vous si vous êtes assumez ce genre de
proposer madame moi citoyen français que
je suis
issu du 93 de la ville
d'Aulnay-sous-Bois tu ne pourrais jamais
tolérer qu'un élu de la République avec
la belle histoire que nous avons qui
était ce genre de Bobo aussi infamant
comme ça normal
que vous tenez vous et vous vous donnez
moi les images de TPMP alors que TPMP
voilà vous êtes d'accord voyons merci à
Théo quand même parce que Théo je l'ai
appelé hier très tard car j'avais pas à
dormir je l'appelle vers les entre 23h30
il m'a décroché il m'a dit Adam il y a
pas de problème je vais contacter Cyril
et je suis là aujourd'hui je suis
vraiment le remercier non mais attends
dans la vraie question la vraie question
que j'ai envie est-ce que tu as pu
dormir avant de venir
merci d'avoir regardé
[Applaudissements]
mon frère
où on entend quelque chose encore
bien sûr parce que dès qu'on est dans
une minorité on est on est on est
blessés par des choses mais en revanche
que tu puisses arriver ici est-ce qu'on
peut faire un débat de temps en temps je
te dis un black et un blanc français
de couleur différente sans que ça tombe
sans le terrassiste ou tu es raciste
est-ce que ça c'est possible alors tu
vois bah déjà me dire je suis pas là bas
moi je suis blanche ou quoi
tu me connais tes mots tu es vraiment
quelqu'un que j'aime énormément et tu le
sais à chaque fois tu me demandes de
venir s'il vous plaît à chaque fois que
tu me dois en devenir je te dis toujours
oui parce que j'ai
et je te le dis ni Géraldine ni Mathieu
alors je peux te dire ah merde je te le
dire ça merci
les gens au contraire c'est tout le
contraire voilà la chose que j'ai en ma
qualité de révolutionnaire et vu quand
même je suis à minimum instruit
des mots il y a aucun moment
je parle juste des propos xénophobes
caractères racistes qui ont été
proférées
aujourd'hui voir des des présentateurs
de TPMP
avoir des personnes comme ça c'est
regarder
les quartiers il est cités tenir ce
genre d'assure c'est devenu normal
c'est pas normal moi j'ai subi quoi j'ai
pris une prise de position par rapport à
une directive qui avait été donnée par
le ministère de l'intérieur on a
carrément fait une pétition contre moi
pour que je retourne en Afrique madame
madame merci